mais elle a une ce soir on revient sur
le procès de l'incendiaire des quartiers
présents des faits votes l'auteur a
écopé d'une peine de 18 mois
d'emprisonnement dont 12 avec sursis
probatoire de 2 ans il s'agit d'un
policier auxiliaire de 22 ans originaire
du Cher il était jugé cet après-midi en
comparution immédiate pour avoir mis le
feu à plusieurs poubelles à Tours le 6
août dernier les flammes c'était propagé
détruisant 13 voitures et endommageant
plusieurs façades de maison Florent
Clavel était au tribunal
en ce mois de septembre Tom aurait dû
intégrer l'école de police de Rouen pour
devenir gardien de la paix mais voilà
l'aspirant policier assis dans le box
cuisiné par le président d'audience
comme un vulgaire délinquant accablé par
la honte le jeune homme de 22 ans va
d'ailleurs craquer à plusieurs reprises
il faut dire que ces états de service
après cette nuit du 6 août sont
rédhibitoires 20 poubelles carbonisées
13 voitures des facettes de maison et ça
dans plusieurs rue de la ville mais
surtout une nuit de terreur pour les
habitants ma mère fait partie d'une des
victimes une voiture plusieurs voitures
ont pris feu devant chez elle rue du
cuzel le problème c'est qu'elle avait 88
ans elle se trouvait à l'étage juste au
dessus de l'endroit où les flammes ont
déjà fondu les persiennes une de mes
sœurs était sur place était complètement
paniqué en voyant par les fenêtres les
flammes qui étaient juste devant la
maison pour expliquer son geste le
rugbyman amateur évoque une
alcoolisation massive et chronique ainsi
qu'une grande colère une rupture
amoureuse l'expertise psychiatrique
souligne d'ailleurs une impulsivité et
une incapacité à gérer ses émotions en
revanche s'il reconnaît les faits il ne
se souvient de rien blackout dit-il
l'auxiliaire de police de Vierzon fera
pourtant preuve d'une grande lucidité
cette nuit-là résistance à berner des
collègues qui le contrôle et a mené ceux
de la BAC sur une fausse piste mais pour
son avocat Tom nourrit de réels regrets
il a conscience de la gravité de son
geste le fait de pas donner
d'explication pour l'accusation c'est
nécessairement du DDI ou une volonté pas
assumer ses responsabilités c'est pas du
tout le cas je pense véritablement que
c'est un garçon qui n'arrive pas à
comprendre véritablement ce qui s'est
passé ce soir là qui indique qu'il a eu
quelques bribes quelques flashs qui ont
fait que il a pu se rappeler de tel ou
tel élément mais évidemment pour la
défense c'est plutôt perturbant après
trois quarts d'heure de délibéré le
tribunal qu'on a de Tom à 18 mois de
prison dont 12 avec sursile devra donc
rester incarcéré encore 6 mois l'ex
policier qui veut désormais devenir
carrossier au plombier devra également
indemniser les victimes à hauteur de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'euros
au titre du préjudice moral et matériel